screaming overhead flying low to avoid
detection ukrainian jets head to the
front line battle
they don't have many left
in recent days there's been a change in
atmosphere here in the donbass a sense
that the russians have momentum
there's a constant stream of farm
machinery being moved back from the
areas most at risk of falling the
country's crucially important farming
industry can't afford to lose this
equipment either stolen or destroyed in
this battle of artillery
moving to the equally precious cargo of
military hardware
it's being repositioned for sure but
further back
everyone here knows that if the russians
get through the cities and the major
towns they're going to come down this
road and through the fields that
surround it
there are defensive lines but without
heavy artillery they're going to be
incredibly difficult to defend
we drove into the town of bahmut
it's undoubtedly one of the next towns
the russians will want to take it's
already being pummeled
there aren't many people left in the
center anymore homes destroyed and
there's a constant sound of shelling
[Music]
moving from town to town on often near
empty roads you have to negotiate
checkpoints and defensive positions
danette's new regional capital
kramatorsk is eerily quiet
here i met pavlo kirilenko he's the
governor of donetsk the next region most
at risk in this war
ukraine has plenty of fighters he told
me but it's desperate for heavy weapons
[Music]
one final question if you don't go at
those weapons
sometimes
[Music]
the coming days are crucial in this war
ukraine's resistance is undimmed but the
scale of the russian resources is slowly
grinding that resistance down
stuart ramsey sky news in the donbass